Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
video all about how marvel is using the hawkeye
series to set up daredevil and young avengers
projects if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
just let me know what you want them to do with
the daredevil characters in the mcu during marvel
phase 4 because it seems like a bunch of them are
coming back really soon careful for spoilers from
hawkeye episode 1 and episode 2 if you haven't
seen the first couple of episodes yet but a little
while ago the showrunner of hawkeye said that
there were a couple of big fan favorite characters
and story lines that he pitched to marvel for
the hawkeye series that kevin feige told him he
couldn't use because they were already using them
in other marvel series in movies and during that
interview he also talked a lot about kate bishop
setting up young avengers he also talked a lot
about daredevil characters so what i'll do is
i'll talk about the daredevil easter eggs and
how hawkeye is setting that up in different ways
like they're still doing daredevil stuff very
clearly and vincent d'onofrio seems like he's
doing everything he can to let everybody know
that he is in the hawkeye series and then i'll
talk about the young avengers easter eggs and how
they're setting that up during the hawkeye series
but during the past couple of episodes most of
you have spotted some of the bigger daredevil
easter eggs there are some that are more obvious
than others a lot of the episodes take place in
hell's kitchen we've already got a major confirmed
daredevil character in episode two echo she's
obviously getting her own spin-off series and i'll
talk about how that's also going to be related to
daredevil but it was no coincidence that they
introduced her character bathes in red light
they're doing everything they can to make you
think of daredevil most of you also probably
know that they borrowed a lot of the plot from
the matt fraction hawkeye run kingpin is also a
big character during that as well during episode
one kate bishop her mother eleanor bishop jack
duquesne aka swordsman all attend a gala event at
this black market auction that takes place at the
same hotel kingpin bought and used as his home
base during daredevil season 3. that was one of
the biggest comments i saw in my episode one video
isn't that the same hotel that kingpin bought
during daredevil season three you are correct
so pat yourself on the back if you spotted that
while kate bishop is snooping around the hotel
she overhears a conversation where armond duquesne
jack's rich uncle is yelling at her mother eleanor
claiming he's learned some dirty secret about her
business bishop security claiming that her empire
was built on lies and that she shouldn't push him
around or try anything sus because he also has
powerful friends then later he's mysteriously
found dead murdered with all kinds of theories
about who did it and why more on that in a second
but the powerful friends line is also supposed to
be a kingpin new york city mob reference because
of the ties the kate bishop's family has to the
mob in the comics now in the comics it was her
father but it seems like for the series they've
changed that to be her mother and her mother is
the one that's in with the mob you can also
see that when the tracksuit mafia raids the
auction looking for the watch which itself is
a huge easter egg they're all wearing red like
red track suits eleanor is wearing a very deep
red dress it also asks kate bishop before they
go to the gala to put on a red dress that she
picked out for her when the raid on the auction
actually goes down later bomb explodes alarms
going off everywhere the whole ballroom just
erupts upstairs and panic people fleeing running
everywhere eleanor does not seem bothered at
all like she's not surprised the only time she
actually shows any concern is when kate bishop
disappears and she starts worrying about her as if
to imply that eleanor was somehow in on the heist
also jack ducane swordsman doesn't seem like he
was particularly surprised by the raid when it
happens he just casually picks up hawkeye's
ronin sword from the rubble like he knew
it was going to happen the whole time so the
early theory is that eleanor is controlling
the tracksuit mafia using bishop security and
they're just this very low-level group of bumbling
villains mostly there for comedic relief which
is the way that matt fraction used them in his
hawkeye run mostly there for comedic relief like
very low level enforcers and here's where we bring
it back around to daredevil kingpin setting that
up in the background during episode 2 hawkeye lets
himself be captured by the tracksuits so that
he can find out how far this goes up the food
chain like who is your boss i would like to speak
to your manager i came here to talk to your boss
i mean is that him there i would really
like to speak to your boss that's why
they tell him she wants him alive and the she i
think that they were referring to is meant to be
echo echo is a core daredevil character from the
comics like i said they introduce her bathed in
red light just like daredevil during his comics
she started out as a villain but then becomes
more of an anti-hero falling in love with him her
father was an enforcer for kingpin until he killed
him then lied to echo framing daredevil for the
murder raising her to be an assassin really badass
assassin at that and eventually used her against
daredevil until she learned the truth the kingpin
really killed her father we're supposed to get
some of ekko's backstory during that we'll see her
father in flashbacks so they'll be a version of
that storyline they might just switch it and have
ronin be the person who killed her father but this
is what it seems like the power structure is like
inside the hawkeye episodes at the bottom you have
the tracksuits casual enforcers bumbling idiots
echo seems like she's in charge of them and
echo and the tracksuits are probably working for
eleanor bishop who's using her bishop security
technology to help the more powerful new york
city mob families and it seems like she's just
using the tracksuits for her grunt work like
raiding the auction to get the watch then above
eleanor bishop is probably kingpin she's probably
secretly working for him using bishop's security
to help him control new york city on the dl
and kingpin himself is just using his original
tactics of staying in the shadows off everyone's
radar for those of you asking about the continuity
of this like if they're bringing the daredevil
characters back which it seems like they are like
vince d'onofrio's kingpin charlie cox's daredevil
character some of the other netflix daredevil
characters coming back does that mean that they'll
try to canonize the events of the daredevil series
the way charlie cox explained it is if they all
came back it would probably be sort of a creative
reimagining so i'm not expecting when they do come
back for them to reference a lot of what happened
during daredevil season three for instance
like when kingpin eventually shows up in the mcu
he will probably still be a bit of a mystery to
most people it would probably happen to kate and
eleanor after the battle of new york just charting
the timeline here about how eleanor got in with
the kingpin early theory her father said that they
were about to go bankrupt but he had this plan to
fix that her mother had that line about solutions
not falling out of the sky well early theory her
father saw the battle of new york go down five
seconds later shatauri literally falling from the
sky is an opportunity to fake his death so that
maybe eleanor could collect the insurance money
save her and kate from bankruptcy and eleanor
just use that money to start bishop's security and
develop those connections to the new york city mob
kingpin who helped the business grow and turn
it into this empire quote unquote built on lies
like armand was yelling at her i should
have known your empire was built on lies
during episode 1 she talks a lot about how
she didn't come from money she was poor
unlike kate's father who grew up in a rich
family if you remember kingpin is the exact
same he grew up in a very poor new york city
family then slowly built his crime empire so
it would make sense that he in eleanor see eye to
eye on a lot of things i'm also starting to like
the theory now that it was actually eleanor who
had armand killed to prevent him from digging too
deep into her bishop's security business and
learning about her secret ties to kingpin
so other side theory her mother will probably wind
up being the mcu version of madame mask who is a
long-time kate bishop antagonist and shows up
during the matt fraction hawkeye run she also
runs a bit of a shady black market auction like
the one we saw in episode one it also seems like
eleanor is hiding some special fighting skills too
and that's why i think they had that scene of her
flipping the food in episode one into her mouth
just to show you that she does have some skills
in bringing back around to the echo character
who's gonna be really big during the rest of
the episodes there's a report that during her
spin-off series we already know they're doing
it they hyped it up during the big disney plus day
presentation they're gonna use that to bring back
most of the core daredevil netflix characters and
it'll feel kind of like a daredevil season four
and then after that the characters will go on
to a full-blown daredevil revival series on
disney plus for those of you that want them to
do a new daredevil series with those characters
there have also been a lot of rumors about
charlie cox showing up for a cameo scene during
spider-man no way home and also showing up in the
marvel she-hulk series so like i said the hawkeye
showrunner sounded like he wanted to use charlie
cox's daredevil during hawkeye and kevin feige
told him no because we're already using him in a
bunch of other things right now as for the young
avengers easter eggs the show runner also spent
a lot of time talking about how their version of
haley steinfeld's kate bishop was meant to feel
like the young avengers version of kate bishop as
opposed to the matt fraction version because even
though they're doing the matt fraction comic book
story during that she's actually more the voice of
reason and it's hawkeye that's the crazy one and
they've kind of reversed that so like hawkeye is
the person who's trying to be reasonable and mcu
kate bishop is being a little bit crazier he also
referenced some young avengers storylines about
kate bishop being with the young avengers and
like i said he claims kevin feige told him there
were a couple story lines that he couldn't do or
reference because they were already doing those in
other series and movies we know that they're doing
some young avengers setup in ant-man 3 quantumania
because they recast cassie lang's stature with
an even bigger actress and they have kang the
conqueror long time young avengers villain during
hawkeye episode 1 a lot of you noticed the watch
the tracksuits try to steal is a huge young
avengers easter egg there were a lot of comments
about this on my episode one video when they hold
it up the lot 268 number is an easter egg for
avengers 268 a big kang the conqueror storyline so
a watch a timepiece kang the conqueror master of
time during marvel phase 4. we know we're going
to see many different versions of the character
in upcoming projects different variants in loki
season 2 ant-man 3 perhaps also during a young
avengers series because we know they're doing
young avengers setting up in the background of a
lot of these marvel phase four projects with the
different members of the team from that initial
roster like we have billy and tommy that we got
during wand division we'll probably see older
versions of their characters in the future now we
have kate bishop from the hawkeye series we have
cassie lang coming there are other members of the
team they could substitute like kamala khan's miss
marvel and riri williams originally what i think
the hawkeye showrunner wanted to do was have more
overt young avengers easter eggs and kevin feige
is probably like no no you get to back off on that
because we're already kind of using ant-man 3 for
some of that but there'll be a lot more daredevil
and more young avengers easter eggs in the rest of
the episode so when we see those i'll be sure to
point those out in my videos my full hawkeye
episode 3 video will post next on wednesday
just like normal so make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss that
everyone click here for my brand new spider-man
no way home trailer video and click here to
learn all about them doing spider-man 4 in
a brand new trilogy of spider-man movies
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!